we are fighters and burn and this is the
extra step at craft event we're doing
festival high-fashion in San Francisco
and you can certainly smell the
patchouli oh that's the smell of
flip-flops and people being okay with it
are you getting good vibes bad vibes gel
vibe
happy vibe San Francisco vibes I love
the vibe I'm just wearing what I wore to
my friend's wedding was this like an
acid wedding somebody there was on that
for sure got a strong tuck in and you've
got a really good eye catching her like
the Lady Gaga of the ocean oh my god
it's Doug your nemesis it's me psychic
who you ignored you feeling like you
found the worst crime ever in fashion
versus a male romper new daring bathroom
we're going to strike a pose Audrey
ready one two three
I think we finally found our favorite
part of festival culture the VIP lounge
cheered for that yes